- Good morning Believe
Nation, today's message is
"be a great leader."
Over to you, John Addison.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Weather veins typically are
politicians, where whatever
way the wind's blowing or
whatever the mood of the
moment is, whatever the polls
say, they spin that direction.
Leaders are lighthouses,
there's a consistency to it,
there's a strength to it.
Lighthouses are only needed
when the weather's stormy,
when it's beautiful they're
just a pretty building.
But when the seas are stormy
and it's dark and rainy
and foggy, that's when
you need a lighthouse,
a leader has to be a rock.
Someone of consistency with
the storms whether it's
in business, the economy,
whatever's happening to
the organization that you're
over, that you're a human
Alka Seltzer, you calm the organization.
I've worked for people
that were quote en quote
leaders, who would bring
a bucket of gas to a fire
and make it just turn
it into a blaze by how
they reacted to it.
Great leaders are calmers,
great leaders are people that
when maybe everything is
hectic and chaotic, but when
people see them, hear
from them, they're calmer.
I believe a peaceful mind generates power.
- If you want to do something
great then you're going to
need to build a team,
whether it's in business,
whether it's some other
movement that you want to build,
if you want to do something
great, you can't do it alone,
you need a team!
And so many people go through
this as they're building
their business, often
they hire the wrong person
at the start and it doesn't
work out, and they say
"you know what, forget this,
I'm just going to go back
"to doing everything myself!"
And that is not the answer.
The answer is to learn
how to be a better leader.
As your organization gets
bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger, your
role, the contribution you're
giving actually diminishes.
If you have 100 people in
your company, the thing that
you're doing day in and day
out is minor compared to what
your 100 other people are doing for you.
When you're solo you're
doing everything, when you
bring on one person maybe
you're doing still 75%
of the value because you're
the best at what you do,
but then as you start
bringing more people on,
your contribution diminishes,
and so yes you're focusing
on what you can become
the best in the world at,
but your greatest contribution
is going to be leading
your team to help unlock
their potential and allowing
them to be the best in
the world at what they do.
We don't go to school for
leadership, we don't really learn
leadership at high school,
we don't learn leadership
at university, there's
no course you can take,
maybe you join a sports team
and maybe you had a coach
who was amazing who guided
you, but this isn't part
of the process for most people.
Most people aren't trained in leadership.
This is why I think
understanding your one word
is really important, when
you know what it is that you
stand for, then it's way
easier to lead a group of
people, it's way easier to
build a team of people who are
aligned with what you're trying to do.
I believe great leadership
is about unlocking the
potential in the people on your team.
They're working on a
certain standard which may
already be high but you
see them being able to
work up here.
And your job is to help
them close that gap through
believing in them, through pushing them,
through training them,
you have to help them
close that gap, that's what
I believe a great leader
does and the way to do
it, the easiest way in my
experience is through
understanding their one work
in their credo.
Understanding what drives them.
They are giving you the
tools to help push them.
So for example somebody
really values creativity,
versus somebody who really values grit.
Hard work and grit versus
creativity, those don't have
to be opposites, but it's
something that they really value.
And so yes we have
organizational goals, here's what
we're trying to reach, I
want to help entrepreneurs,
I want to get to one million
subscribers, that's our next
goal, we're aligned around that.
But the people on my team, how
do we go and accomplish it?
If somebody really values
creativity then I need to push
them on creativity, I need
more creative solutions.
I need creative editing, I
need creative videographing.
Is that a word?
I need creative thumbnails,
I need more creativity.
Where if somebody's word is
grit or part of their credo
was grit, then I need them to work harder.
I need them to push themselves.
If somebody's word is
"extraordinary," then how can we make
this more extraordinary?
What do we need to do, I
need extraordinary thumbnails
I need extraordinary videography,
I need extraordinary editing.
I can't make somebody who
values creativity and push
them to extraordinary,
it's just not who they are,
there's going to be a disconnect.
So understanding what our
goal is, having a common goal
and then giving people the
flexibility and freedom
to help you accomplish that
goal in a way that best suits
them and you understanding
them, their one word,
their credo, they're giving
you the tools to push them.
They're giving you the tools
to close that gap, between
where they're at now and
where their potential is
which in my view is the
ultimate goal of a leader.
So the question today is I'm
curious, are you a leader
and how many people are on your team?
Could be full time, could
be contractors, I'm curious
how many people are on your
team right now, leave in
the comments below, super
curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Daniel Burgess,
Daniel thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, really really
means a lot to me man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe
in yourself, and whatever
your one word is.
I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for another
show of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- My last paycheck, I
still remember it clearly,
it was one of the worst and
the best days of my life.
I was in Puerto Rico, I
was working for Xerox,
and my boss gave me my
last, it wasn't a paycheck,
it was a bonus check, I
think it was about 30,000
bucks, taxable, only problem with that.
So I get this check and
I went "holy mackerel."
I was excited but i was also disturbed.
And so this other guy comes
up to me, his name was John,
and John says to me, "you're
going to be back," I said "why?"
He says "because you're going to fail."
I looked at him and said
"look," few explative words,
because that's what he did, he left Xerox,
failed and came back.
I said "look da da da, you
failed and you came back,
"but I'm going to fail and I'm
never coming back," and that's
the attitude, you know what I mean?
If you say "well if I fail I'll
go back to Mommy and Daddy,"
then that's what you'll do.
So if you fail, that's when
I became an entrepreneur
because I had no money,
I had no money for years.
I didn't have a paycheck.
But that's what my rich
dad encouraged me to do,
he said when you don't have
this paycheck, you get hungrier,
smarter, and it's a
test of your character.
Will you become a crook,
will you become dishonest,
will you cheat and steal,
or will you become a
better human being?
So really that's the benefit
of becoming an entrepreneur,
you really find out who you are when
you don't have anything.
When you're an entrepreneur
and you're going to be
a big entrepreneur, leadership
skills and communication
skills are more important
than a law degree.
So I have another boko that
just came out, it's called
The Eight Lessons in Military
Leadership, and the military,
went to Military Academy and all that.
From day one you're learning
leadership, day one at
the academy I have to stand
in front of 20 18 year
old kids and go "section, 10 hut!"
And that's when they're
going to say "screw you."
so that's when you learn to be a leader.
Now as you said to me when
we first met, the trouble
with the military, they're a little rough.
So I had a hard time when
I came back from Vietnam
and I went to work for
Xerox and people don't like
the idea of calling them
an asshole and f-head
and stuff like that.
- Every other word is a
curse word in the military.
- Hey f-head, you're not doing this.
But they don't, (gasp) "I'm
going to call the HR person!"
I better make some changes, you
know what I'm talking about?
- Of course I do.
- You can't talk straight
in corporate America.
- In the military you can.
- You have to, they love it.
- You actually get promotions if you do it
in the military.
- When I got called names it
was "oh the guy likes me."
So that's why all you guys
who are military veterans,
you have probably the number
one skill to be an entrepreneur
which is leadership, the
ability to listen, to not take
it personally, and still get the job done.
It is the best training in the world.
Saddest saying about
leaving the military was
leaving the guys behind there.
They were some of the
best in the world and they
weren't all college graduates,
they were just gunners,
mechanics, all this stuff.
- Camaraderie.
- Oh just priceless!
- Camaraderie is priceless.
- It's all I did when I
started the Rich Dad company
was to have that same sense
of teamwork inside Rich Dad,
that's why there's no
ranks and all this stuff
in this company, everybody
gets to say what they
want to say, people are
free to do what they want
I stay out of their way,
and we get the job done
- Everyone's not a leader
and we shouldn't expect
everyone to be a leader, I
think it becomes something that
you want to do or you're born with it.
And some people lead by
example, some people lead by
a voice, some people lead by both.
And for me I felt in order
for myself to be as good
as I wanted to be, and
at the same time in order
for our team to be as
good as I wanted it to be,
I had to be both.
As well as we played last
game it aint going to be
enough to win tonight!
You got to give more dog,
you got to protect more,
you got to help more, you got
to sacrifice more in order
to get this win.
- You have a lot of different
styles, let's throw out
some of them, you're like
a wise teacher sometimes.
- Yeah.
- Tell me about that one.
- I don't know man, like
you said, I got so many
different forms of leadership,
and it just comes from
my personality, at times I can be silly.
Strike three!
Man he's beautiful, he's got
me looking like Iron Man.
And at times I can be serious.
If you know personnel you
know teammates, you throw
it up to the rim.
That's like you throwing
that same pass to Shaq,
would you do that to Shaq, you won't throw
that pass to Shaq.
At times I can be like a
teacher and be like focusing
in on all my students.
I throw right here so if I
need to step one at least
I'm only stepping right here.
At times I can be the student,
and to be able to have
different forms of leadership
has helped me because
you have different personalities
in the locker room.
Everybody is not the same.
The way I talk to D. Wade
may not be the way I talk
to Chris or the way I talk
to Chris may not be the way
I talk to UD or to Burr, or to Reel.
Big time man, big time.
Everyone's personality is
different so my leadership skills
has different phases because
I understand what I'm
doing with them.
I love you, I love you!
They go crazy! (screaming)
Whoever misses me now,
whoever misses is out!
Five, four, three, two, one!
- [Interviewer] Sometimes
you know to smile in
leadership, sometimes the
playful LeBron, sometimes you use
that as a form of leadership.
- [LeBron] Absolutely, I
got that from being around
my childhood friends, we
used to have so much fun man.
But we understood when that
ball was tipped, we going to
have the most fun here.
And I just brought that with
me to the MBA, when you're
doing something that way and
it's working and you're winning
and you're not disrespecting
the game, this is what you
feel like is how it's supposed to be done.
It's given me a sense of
brotherhood in this league
that is hard to come by.